dans les épisodes précédents on a vu que
le machine learning moderne consiste est
souvent être guidé dans l'exploration
des paramètres de nos algorithmes à
l'aide de gradient c'est gradient nous
disent comment ajuster nos paramètres
pour mieux coller aux données
d'entraînement
cependant j'ai pu malencontreusement
donner l'impression que cette
exploration des paramètres allaient
nécessairement bien se passer et nous
conduira à déterminer des paramètres
optimaux pour nos machines
ce n'est malheureusement absolument pas
le cas l'exploration par descente de
gradient c'est une exploration bien plus
intelligente qu'une exploration
aléatoire cependant il reste difficile
de garantir quoi que ce soit vis-à-vis
des performances de la descente de
gradient et pour le comprendre il est
utile de considérer l'analogie avec la
topographie des topographies c'est
l'étude des reliefs typiquement pour
dessiner des cartes qui rende compte que
des altitudes des paysages naturels et
en machine learning ou même typiquement
considérer que les coordonnées gps d'un
individu sur terre sont l'équivalent des
paramètres de nos algorithmes alors que
l'altitude correspond à la performance
de l'algorithme typiquement une faible
altitude correspond à un algorithme
performant lors qu'une haute altitude
correspond à un algorithme qui commet
beaucoup d'erreurs de prédiction le
problème d'une machine learning
correspondait alors à identifier des
points de très faible altitude
cependant il faut imaginer que le
paysage global est très difficile à
observer
étant donné deux boutons il est
difficile de visualiser les performances
de la machine pour différents réglages
de ce bouton
souvenez-vous du cadre de l'épisode 42
tout ce que l'on a
ce sont des boutons à tourner et donc on
est limité dans ce qu'on peut faire pour
une configuration donnée on peut
calculer la performance de la machine
mais aussi et surtout dans le cadre des
réseaux de neurones notamment pour
chaque configuration de la machine
on a aussi un gradient qui nous suggère
comment tourner les boutons pour aller
dans le bon sens en topographie ça
correspond à dire que l'on à un capteur
gps qui nous dit exactement où on est
mais on n'a pas de carte pour savoir où
il faut aller
qui plus est on est aveugle ce qui veut
dire qu'on ne peut pas non plus voir le
paysage autour de nous on dispose
toutefois d'un altimètre pour que m
l'altitude et enfin d'une espèce de
super boussole qui nous dit vers où
aller pour descendre autant que possible
cette direction de plus forte descente
est justement ce qu'on appelle le
gradient de la pente
appliquez la descente de gradient sar
vient se placer quelque part dans le
paysage
puis à chaque instant on utilise la
super boussole pour déterminer la
direction de plus forte descente et les
yeux fermés on effectue un pas dans
cette direction
généralement proportionnelle à la pente
de cette direction de plus forte
descente
et puis une fois ce pas effectué on
recommence alors très rapidement dans
l'épisode 42 j'ai mentionné une variante
de la descente auto gradient ap les
stochastiques
ça consiste à avoir une super boussole
imprécise qui en moyenne marche mais qui
donne des indications qui fluctue d'une
mesure à l'autre ça ne change pas
énormément de chose au problème
bref on a donc cette technique de
descente de gradient qui pas à pas et
c'est de nous amener vers de basse
altitude
le succès du machine learning dépend
alors de la faculté de cette descente de
gradient à y parvenir
qu'est-ce qui peut mal aller alors tout
d'abord on peut parler du cas où tout
ira forcément bien c'est typiquement le
cas lorsque le paysage est entièrement
une énorme cuve est si cette cuvette et
bien comme il faut et si nos pas à sont
de plus en plus petit on sent qu'on
finira par atteindre le fond de la
cuvette
eh bien il ya une façon de formaliser
cette intuition une bonne cuvée
correspond à ce que l'on appelle une
fonction de coo convexe intuitivement si
on remplissait la cuvette de goudron
alors le goudron prendrait alors la
forme d'un solide sens creux intel
solide est appelée convexe et ça a bien
sûr des liens avec la géométrie comme
par exemple la possibilité de pavage
pentagonaux de façon un peu plus formel
une cuvette sera convexe si lorsque je
prends deux points de la cuvette et si
je construis une tyrolienne qui relie
ces deux points alors la tyrolienne ne
touchera jamais le sol dit encore
autrement tout moyenne pondérée des
altitudes des deux points sera supérieur
à l'altitude de la moyenne pondérée des
deux poings bref en optimisation
on s'est rendu compte encore et encore
que cette propriété de convexité rendait
les problèmes simples et résolument
efficacement ainsi si un informaticien
vous dit qu'un problème est complexe
vous pouvez généralement comprendre
qu'il vous dit qu'il est facile et en
effet typiquement ses métriques de
performance à minimiser son complexe
alors on peut démontrer que la descente
de gradient va bien marcher
malheureusement à l'instar de la
topographie les performances des réseaux
de neurones de forme généralement pas
une gentille cuvette globale pour
commencer on peut avoir des cuvettes
locale typiquement le relief peut être
miné de petit creux à l'instar de la
surface de la lune disons la descente de
gradient valeurs nous faire tomber dans
l'un de ces creux mais probablement pas
dans le plus bas de ces creux or il est
tout à fait possible que la plupart des
creux soit en haute altitude par
opposition à un maxi cros qui serait
l'équivalent de la fosse des mariannes
en fait si on appliquait la descente de
gradient sur terre il serait improbable
d'atteindre une altitude comparable à la
plus basse altitude possible on finirait
bien plus probablement dans des creux en
altitude
peut-être même au dessus du niveau de la
mer comme le fond d'un lac
dans le jargon on dit qu'on attendra des
minimales locaux par opposition à la
fosse des mariannes qui serait un
minimum
global et il faut bien dire que machine
learning on a fini par accepter cette
défaillance de la descente de gradient
il est même considéré illusoire
aujourd'hui d'espérer atteindre des
minimes à globo on se satisfait
généralement bien aisément de minima
locaux après tout s'il y a atteint des
performances surhumaine à sa tâche c'est
déjà pas mal
et d'ailleurs on peut invoquer des
arguments de complexité en temps de
calcul pour conclure que chercher des
minimes à globo est désespérée en effet
en s'appuyant par exemple sur le
problème du voyageur de commerce il est
aisé de construire des familles de
fonctions telles que trouver les minima
globaux de ses fonctions soit un
problème
np dur et npd or ça veut dire ça veut
dire super dur go bref le mieux qu'on
puisse espérer en pratique c'est sans
doute les minimales locaux mais du coup
si on laisse tourner la descente de
gradient on finira au moins par
atteindre des minimales locaux non eh
bien ce n'est pas gagné en effet une
autre chose qui peut arriver et de se
retrouver bloqué au niveau d'un col en
montagne un col correspond à
l'intersection entre une ligne de crête
et une ligne de creux typiquement en
randonnée au monde souvent le long de
ligne de creux pour rejoindre d'école et
c'est souvent génial parce qu'en
arrivant au niveau du col
on découvre tout à coup la vue de
l'autre côté du col en descente de
gradient on aura plus tendance à
descendre plus ou moins le long d'une
ligne de crête
avant d'arriver au col et le problème
c'est qu'au niveau du col le gradient
s'annulent
ce qui fait que les pas du gradient sont
très petit et peu indicatif de la bonne
direction à suivre pour descendre alors
pour les cols de montagne ça ne paraît
pas si problématique puisqu'il semble
qu'on finira bien par tomber d'un côté
ou de l'autre du col mais cette
intuition que l'on finit
assez vite par tomber d'un côté ou de
l'autre est assez spécifique des petites
dimensions
oui parce que les coordonnées gps
correspondent à de nombreux la latitude
et la longitude est donc la topographie
terrestre correspond à uniquement de
boutons d'une machine que l'on
chercherait à paramétrer en pratiquant
machine learning
on a souvent des millions de boutons et
il se peut que l'on est alors un col qui
soit une ligne de crête selon 990 mille
direction et une ligne de creux selon
les 10000 direction restantes
mais alors il faut imaginer que notre
boussole surtout si elle est randomisés
va souvent nous amener vers une
combinaison d un million de direction
qui va alors avoir de bonnes chances
d'aller globalement dans l'es9 190000
mauvaise direction
plutôt que dans les dix mille direction
restantes et le truc c'est une telle
direction bonne faire remonter plutôt
que des cendres trouver l'une des
directions qui descendent et bien les
prendre
peut être redoutablement difficile car
en grande dimension l'angle admissible
pour descendre peut-être ridiculement
petit bref il se trouve que en pratique
l'école de très grandes dimensions sont
des obstacles très difficile à franchir
pour la descente de gradient et du coup
oui il faut parfois se contenter des
cols plutôt que des cuvettes
ce qui nous amène à la question suivante
ces histoires de cul est non globale et
de colle au final est ce si grave
et bien pas nécessairement en 2015
certains chercheurs ont étudié les
propriétés de certaines ipea surface
aléatoire et l'ont montré qu'en un
certain sens les cuvettes écoles étaient
généralement pas si mal autrement dit en
général
tombé dans une cuvette ce n'est pas une
garantie d'avoir bien appris mais c'est
un signe qu'on a bien progressé et c'est
sans doute comme ça qu'il vaut mieux
interpréter le machine learning
d'ailleurs il est bon de garder en tête
que même le minimum global n'est
globalement meilleures que vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble des données collectées et ne
le restera probablement pas si on
collecte toujours plus de données
surtout si ces autres données
correspondent à quelque chose d'un peu
différent
ainsi selon cette vision du machine
learning il faut surtout cherché à
beaucoup progressé plutôt que de
chercher à être optimal vis-à-vis de ce
qui a été observé jusque là enfin une
dernière particularité géologique qui
peut avoir des conséquences étonnantes
en apprentissage et la présence de
falaise ainsi il est possible qu'un
apprentissage soit bloqué sur
la taupe avant de soudain tombé d'une
falaise bon et irl vous déconseille de
tomber d'une falaise maison machine
learning cela correspondrait à tout à
coup à atteindre des performances
nettement meilleures
et je me demande si ce n'est pas ça qui
m'arrive de temps en temps dans
l'apprentissage des mathématiques
parfois je bloque des heures des jours
parfois même des mois sur un concept
mais tout à coup en l'espace parfois
d'une fraction de seconde tout s'éclaire
bon ça arrive pas aussi souvent que
j'aimerais mais quand ça arrive c'est
l'une des sensations les plus cultes
issoire bref globalement il me semble
que l'analogie entre la descente de
gradient l apprenti c'est avec les
humains ne soient pas si farfelue dans
les deux cas d'une certaine manière il
s'agit d'explorer l'espace des idées en
étant guidé par des données empiriques
deux sortes n'ont pas à chercher à
apprendre l'idée optimale mais plutôt à
simplement constamment cherché à mieux
faire l'anr fin on a parlé de
l'algorithme devrait être aux
populations il avait notamment donné un
exemple où on essayait de détecter des
chars ou pas et on mesurait la
performance de l'algorithme avec le
carré de l'erreur entre paix et la
valeur attendue qui étaient soit 0 ou
soit un pour la présence ou l'absence de
chats et j'avais invité aussi une
remarque comme quoi en fait entre l2 et
l1 ça changeait pas énormément de choses
bon en fait c'est pas tout et faudra ça
change pas mal de choses parce que
changer des choses en tout cas et c'est
ce que fait remarquer nicolas aborderont
notamment la métrique l1 est souvent
quelque chose de beaucoup plus robuste
elle sera beaucoup moins sensible à
notamment des des erreurs d'étiquetage
si on a une image de chats mais elle a
été étiqueté pas achats en fait du coup
la fonction objectifs qu'on a programmé
d'intelligence artificielle sur à
quelque chose qui ne sera pas en fait la
bonne réponse attendue parce qu'on avait
fait une erreur d'étiquetage et et
lorsqu'on utilise une erreur quadratique
ça donne beaucoup plus importance à ces
erreurs d'étiquetage et on a déjà parlé
notamment avec midi en parlant
de robustesse notamment vis-à-vis des
attaques contre les ya ce genre de
différence entre le carré et la valeur
absolue et en fait assez important pour
garantir toujours plus de robustesse du
coup pour des raisons de robustesse il
peut être souhaitable de préférer la
valeur absolue plutôt que le carré de
l'erreur bon bien sûr la gamme des
histoires de très neuf dans parce que si
on prend le car et de l'erreur
à ce moment là on est capable avoir en
fait une meilleure cuve est en fait qu a
été beaucoup plus plu lis beaucoup plus
plus ronde et beaucoup plus complexes en
un sens en ce sens qui peut être même
vendu assez précis et ça c'est du coup
plus souhaitable c'est nous oriente
mieux dans la descente de gradient tout
cas ça permet à descendre de gratteurs
de converger plus rapidement vers des
bonnes solutions
peut-être qu'une bonne idée dans
certaines applications sa dépendance à
des applications
mais dans un premier temps il peut être
souhaitable de regarder d'abord
dépénalisation quadratique comme ça ça
va nous permettre de bien explorer
l'espace des idées de pression assez
globale et ensuite une fois qu'on a des
bonnes performances
on peut chercher à avoir plutôt des
erreurs en valeur absolue qui vont nous
éviter d'être sensibles à des attaques
notamment ou à des données corrompues et
à ce moment là on gagnera en robustesse
et tout en continuant à ça à progresser
dans notre apprentissage
ap qui voit lui demande bas sachant que
la descente de grayan stochastique et
l'algrave doit être prise à sion ont
déjà été découverts avec eux bongo ça
fait pas mal de temps et qu'on a rien su
découvrir de nouveaux et de meilleurs
depuis cela depuis au moins trois
décennies
est-ce que c'est à dire que les frais
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire maintenant en
termes de recharge artificielle est bien
et ce qui encore énormément énormément
de recherches sur l'intelligence
artificielle à faire et on a déjà des
repères parler pas mal dans cette série
notamment en termes de robustesse des
intelligences artificielles il ya des
tout ce pan de recherche
il ya aussi plein de problèmes de
comment extraire la sémantique de
données et à ce moment là en fait on va
voir en tant que l'on parlera
dégénérative à dire sur les networks
mais l'idée d'utiliser juste la
rétrogration ne suffit pas parce qu'on
n'aura pas des données étiquetés et du
coup va falloir trouver des façons de
combiner notamment plusieurs
architectures de réseaux de neurones et
des algorithmes d'asie aidée et
de rétro progression mais avec des
fonctions objectif bien choisi pour que
on arrive quand même à faire des trucs
intelligents tout en exploitant et
sgd descendre de gradient stochastique
et la rétrogration vient en parlera un
peu plus tard dans cette série et aussi
peut-être des architectures de réseaux
neurones à optimiser ses aussi on en
parlera par exemple notamment les idées
de réseaux de neurones récurrents avec
des boucles qui sont capables d'oublier
l'information de ses boucles ou encore
des histoires de convolution avec le
choix de certains liens plutôt que
d'autres le partage de serre pour moi
bref y'a pas mal le plein de petites
idées comme ça pour améliorer les
architectures de réseaux de neurones
d'aujourd'hui pour faire des
performances qui sont toujours un peu
meilleur d'un point de vue théorique est
encore à des questions qui se posent
après la clé pour faire de la recherche
dans ces domaines c'est vraiment ne pas
être trop ambitieux de pas vouloir
réinventer complètement la route voilà
faut se dire que les progrès que l'on va
faire de toi sinon c'est vrai dans la
recherche en général quand un domaine
qui concept bien établi que faire de
physique aujourd'hui cherchait pas à
réinventer toute la physique est ce
qu'on les travaux de physique théorique
sont plus des contributions des pompiers
a rajouté à tout un édifice est assez
grand comme ça qu'il faut penser la
recherche pas espérer tout résoudre mais
il faut espérer
tenez débit fournir des vies qui vont
permettre à d'autres chercheurs de les
réutiliser de créer d'autres billes pour
ajouter des modules important à un
système plus complexe et je pense que
c'est un petit peu comme ça que
fonctionne aujourd'hui la recherche en
intelligence artificielle
à moins que vous voulez faire des trucs
plus révolutionnaire avec un plus grand
impact et là il y aura plus de risques
d'échec également mais par exemple les
problèmes de sécurité en intelligence
artificielle en particulier le problème
de la programmation des valeurs morales
dans une ia et là je vous renvoie vers
l'article que j'ai écrits ou à
identifier pas mal de problèmes plus ou
moins théoriques et je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de boulot à faire sur chacun de
ces domaines
mais encore une fois ce sera dès ce
seront des pierres a ajouté un édifice
il faut pas espérer tout résoudre
dans le cadre d'un travail de recherche
elle espère qu'ils avaient aimé cette
vidéo la pression de voix on va parler
des bêtises des neurones à la fois
biologique et artificiels et de façon
très contrainte ils vont avoir que les
bêtises des neurones sont une propriété
importante et désirable des neurones si
vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à la
lica les commentaires et partager pense
à vous avez
question épisode merci au départ bourdon
et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois
[Musique]